[Musica]
[Applauso]
ciao a tutti spero che state
trascorrendo una giornata interessante e
gate possono aiutarvi nel vostro
percorso e nelle vostre scelte
sono rosa nella vita lavoro come
operatore umanitario
spesso in emergenze sanitarie causate da
epidemie da catastrofi naturali o da
catastrofi provocate dall'uomo come le
guerre che producono distruzione feriti
tanti rifugiati attualmente sono in
pausa dopo aver lavorato quasi due anni
in yemen poi si vedrà
sono una delle fortunate che ha deciso
del suo piano ha molto giovane molto in
effetti da bambina volevo essere suora
infermiera e partire in africa
poi verso l'adolescenza sono passata un
piano ha modificato sorano ma
sicuramente infermiere e sempre con il
sogno di lavorare ma ovunque avessi
potuto essere utile quindi piano è
sempre stato molto diretto molto chiaro
la vita poi si presenta con altre storie
altre proposte e ogni anno passato
ogni esperienza ogni fallimento successo
mi hanno fatto cambiare di strada forse
non tanto non lontana da quel sogno di
quando era ragazzina sono in maniera
diversa è un po come andare in barca io
volevo partire dalle mie bellissime
montagne del trentino e arrivare fino al
mare
poi sono accaduti tanti tantissimi
eventi che mi hanno fatto prendere fiumi
che sembravano veramente non arrivare al
mare ruscelli tanto stretti per la barca
pesante che mi portava in giro delle
volte girando in tondo in un laghetto
talmente bello che magari era meglio
fermarsi
e invece no si continua si va avanti si
deve magari scendere dalla barca per
disincagliarla dalle erbacce dai tronchi
che la bloccano delle volte alleggerirla
da tanti bagagli inutili e pesanti delle
volte ho dovuto fare forza su me stessa
per evitare di stare in quel laghetto
così bello facile da vivere i confort ma
che non arriva al mare e in effetti
nella vita sono tanti piani b e poi
magari si passa che non ci
si arriva fino alla z e ti rendi conto
che i piani sono infiniti che sono un
che cambiano sempre e che va bene così
tanto sto andando verso il mare e il
piano a è sempre li
abbiamo tutti la possibilità di
scegliere il nostro percorso più o meno
in giovane età certo la famiglia agli
amici le possibilità economiche possono
essere un condizionante ma anche in
situazioni critiche
c'è una certa opportunità di scegliere
la strada e la storia della propria vita
e in genere è una scelta che si fa con
il cuore e con l'anima
poi arriva la vita vera il day by day e
cominciano i guai
magari piccoli magari grandi certe volte
sembrano veramente insormontabili per
esempio in myanmar mi ricorderò sempre
un ciclone norme distruzione totale di
parecchie zone della costa del paese si
parte e si ha già in mente alla lista
delle priorità
in questi casi cibo acqua shelters e
cliniche mobili per curare i superstiti
e per il supporto mentale e i bambini da
vaccinare
piano a semplice in effetti sembra poi
arrivi ti trovi davanti alla realtà non
siamo in molti siamo troppo pochi e con
risorse limitate rispetto all'enormità
dei bisogni il personale locale ha già
molto provato anche se molto motivato
non ha molta esperienza e beba i bambini
che volevamo vaccinare se li ha portati
via il ciclone non si sa più da che
parte iniziare peggio chi scegliere di
aiutare dove perché vi arriva veramente
un blocco e la paura di scegliere la
paura di sbagliare è veramente profonda
il peso della responsabilità delle
scelte ancora più grave il piano b ok
cosa facciamo noi il team con il
personale locale cominciamo a discutere
ci arrabbiamo tutti hanno un'idea
diversa di come potrebbe essere un piano
b poi alla fine si arriva fanno insieme
un piano b che magari non è il sogno
perfetto quello immaginato il
pianificato ma è quello che ci auguriamo
possa essere stato meglio il meglio
possibile per i sopravvissuti al
disastro
e va bene così
la paura è presente nella vita di tutti
i giorni
magari nella vita che faccio io è solo
più evidente perché ci sono le guerre le
catastrofi le le malattie la paura c'è e
ogni tanto me lo immagino come una
persona che sia vestita di rosso solo
per farsi notare
aver paura è normale ed è anche molto
salutare non esistono i supereroi tra
gli umani ci sono solo nei cartoni
animati si sa noi invece siamo molto
umani e con tanti nemici ma la persona e
rosso non è sempre una brutta persona e
anche un'amica che ci può aiutare che ci
salva
ho avuto dalle volte molta paura mi ha
obbligata a stoppare tutto il mio
densamente ea riflettere la paura mi ha
costretto a rivedere i piani a cambiare
percorso per evitare quello che la paura
mi faceva vedere di molto pericoloso per
la mia vita o per quella dei miei amici
e colleghi per il lavoro per le mie
relazioni personali e quindi anche la
paura sceglie al server scegliere la
strada migliore da fare anche se questo
implica un piano b c d tanto
l'ispirazione che viene da quel piano di
quando era ragazzina continua forte non
perdo il focus nonostante le paure e
fallimenti e va bene così
ogni tanto invece la paura ci blocca e
questo non va bene
soprattutto quando abbiamo vicino la
paura di sbagliare la paura di essere
criticati la paura di non essere
accettati
queste sono probabilmente le paure più
difficili da gestire
quante volte mi è successo di continuare
i giorni senza far niente di blocco
emotivo john e senza riuscire a muovermi
per queste paure
e in un intervento avevo sbagliato la
valutazione della situazione
nutrizionale dei bambini
il metodo usato non era quello adatto ha
scoperto dopo quindi i risultati erano
usciti sbagliati e potete immaginare
come ci si sente pure se lo sbaglio era
il metodo la frustrazione le conseguenze
erano tutte mie bloccata veramente
ci ho messo un po a digerire mi sono
chiesta se dovevo mollare tutto
poi mi sono guardata intorno ho capito
dove avevo sbagliato e ho capito che
avrei potuto riparare l'errore e così è
stato
e lasciando da parte orgoglio e vergogna
vado oppure come coordinatore aprire i
centri nutrizionali per l'intervento si
va avanti e si riparano i danni meglio
possibile
errare humanum est e non si scorda
l'errore anzi importante non
dimenticarlo mai così magari gli uguali
non se ne fanno più
nelle crisi umanitarie
la paura soprattutto del nuovo e del
diverso di quello che non si conosce è
molto forte ma in effetti la persona e
rosso non è mai da sola insieme io
immagino anche una persona in blu quella
che ci fa vedere il bello è l'amore
nelle persone la motivazione che ci
spinge a continuare nella stessa
direzione
le soddisfazioni di aver fatto un buon
lavoro o almeno di aver fatto il meglio
possibile di averci provato
non c'è mai solo la paura in noi ci sono
anche tutte le cose positive che ci
capitano ogni giorno in modi diversi
quante volte mi sono seduta per il tè
con della gente sconosciuta
correlazione di ascoltare storie diverse
condividere cultura e modi di vivere
diversi
la diversità fa paura sì ma la diversità
è anche meravigliosa secondo me è sale
il pepe della vita
il mondo è un posto che può essere
veramente bellissimo e le sue diversità
dei paesaggi nella gente nelle lingue
nelle culture arti vale veramente la
pena di provare di accettare le
diversità da molto di più di quello che
si può pensare e soprattutto a per cuore
e l'anima
essere curiosi secondo me è l'arma
migliore contro la paura che blocca sono
molto curiosa mi piace osservare e
ascoltare trovo sempre qualcosa di nuovo
e che stimola continuamente le mie
incita a continuare per seguire il mio
sogno di ragazzina per esempio in uno
degli interventi di piedi mia di ebola
ci siamo trovati a lavorare in una zona
dove c'era un sistema tradizionale di
gestione molto particolare di
matriarcato
all'inizio eravamo veramente perplessi
cosa dovevamo fare con le capo villaggio
queste donne vestite in abiti
tradizionali molto particolari che ci
spiavano e che probabilmente dal canto
loro volevano capire che cosa eravamo
venuti a fare da così lontano così
diversi portare il bene o il male
la curiosità e il desiderio di arrivare
al mare mi hanno aiutata ancora una
volta ho quindi deciso di avvicinarle
abbiamo cominciato a discutere
ho chiesto a questo è capo villaggio se
potevano darci una mano
se potevano convincere la loro gente a
venire per farsi curare a praticare le
loro magie per aiutarci a farsi passare
una situazione veramente terrorizzante
come può esserlo una epidemia di ebola e
in effetti hanno fatto un lavoro
magnifico
due mondi talmente diversi che avrebbero
potuto farsi la guerra se la paura
l'avesse avuto e invece no la curiosità
per la diversità e soprattutto il
rispetto reciproco ci hanno aiutato a
risolvere una situazione di crisi tutte
insieme e va bene così alla fine abbiamo
fatto una bella festa tra donne capo
e continuando a parlare di donne e del
piano a io sono stata fortunata
vengo dalla famiglia numerosa dove non
si hanno mai fatto distinzioni tra noi e
ragazzi e ragazze ma la strada per una
donna non è sempre facile io sono
orgogliosa di esserlo e le mie scelte le
ho fatto in quanto persona non in quanto
donna ma bisogna farci i conti
la carriera per una donna implica ancora
oggi scelte di esclusione di
giustificazione spesso in quanto donna
richiesto di dimostrare di essere brava
non è sufficiente esserlo e soprattutto
se si vuole essere una donna leader
vi assicuro che i fiumi diventano molto
meno simpatici e cacciati ruscelli sono
veramente più stretti ma basta tenere
d'occhio il punto d'arrivo il mare il
focus le priorità scelte quelle
importanti e sempre essere orgogliose di
essere donne perché siamo molto
interessanti e possiamo essere molto
forti
non mi è mai piaciuto quando mi dicevano
emissione c'è un capo forte come un uomo
io o no non sono un maschio e non mi s
non mi serve di esserlo per essere forte
su una donna appunto una persona forte
sì come lo possono essere altre persone
donne e uomini non voglio essere
definita donna capo forte perché sembra
che sono un maschio non discuto
fortemente perché sono in una situazione
emozionale questa è una delle belle
scuse per far star zitto le donne no
discuto fortemente perché sono convinta
delle mie ragioni e quindi non sto zitta
semplicemente
finalmente il piano ha il sogno di una
vita la costruzione della mia storia è
quello che ha mai aiutata tantissimo mi
ha fatta forte sapere dove e andavo e
perché prendere dei rischi e sapere che
nonostante tutti i necessari piani b c d
all'infinito nonostante tutte le paure
le frustrazioni e gli sbagli sarei
riuscito a vedere il mare magari alla
fine per una ragione o per l'altra
lo vedrò solo da lontano ma senza
rimorsi ci ho provato e ci sto ancora
provando con forza
grazie per aver ascoltato i top